[Applause]
[Music]
give me one minute and i'll show you how
dataflow can help you
process and enrich data at scale data is
generated in real time from different
sources but capturing processing and
analyzing it is not
easy because it's usually not in the
desired format for your downstream
systems
solution data flow dataflow is a
serverless fast and cost-effective data
processing service for stream and batch
data which removes operational overhead
by automating the infrastructure
provisioning
and auto scaling as your data grows
using dataflow
is easy you read the data from a source
transform it
and write it back into a sink it
provides portability
with the processing pipeline created
using open source apache beam libraries
in the language of your choice and
deploying it as
data flow job which then executes the
processing on worker virtual machines
you can create and run data flow jobs
using the cloud console ui
gcloud cli or the apis you can use
pre-built or custom templates
or write sql statements to develop
pipelines right from bigquery ui
or use ai platform notebooks security is
taken care
of with all the data encrypted at rest
and in transit
with an option to use customer managed
encryption keys
additionally you can use private ips and
vpc service controls to secure the
environment
for all these reasons dataflow is a
great choice for use cases such as
real-time ai
data warehousing or stream analytics so
next time you're looking to process and
enrich any data
take a minute to look at data flow to
learn more check out cloud.google.com
dataflow
[Music]